amore vita mia e mangiato che è mangiato
di buona mamma la parte con questa sera
si è fatta la forza amore però secondo
me non pensavo fosse così cucinare
stirare pulire sono una schiava la
vostra serva nemici lamentone velato ma
chiaramente milano dire che così
pubblicato tesoro ma dato il buongiorno
di amici con un castello con il netto e
un gattino dentro un cestino di viti
anabio sodio è pieno di persone false
tesoro ma il tesoro sei un insensibile
dicevo la descrivendo amen si salvava il
bambino per si parla che suggerì di
avere condividi quel bosco ma è cosa da
fare è pronta ripresa tra immaginate
casta per tutte alla ripetizione 12 in
bagno libero n bastano spiaggia è mamma
era passato ai derivati gemiti creano in
dieci non ci sarà il mio cuore questa
stanza e tuberi spina c'è puzza di
questa casa non è un albergo chi troppo
buoni zullo street
ricordate ma tesoro non lo chef chi
disprezza o ne hai osato lurido verme
combinare poi ieri lunedì sul pavimento
che lo sai che colleghi operato posso
benissimo risorge a te
sparisci dalla mia vista sono arrivate a
chi spetti loro spedite medi mentre
maria amore non mi faccio salvare le
foto su slacciata rolino come mi sta
bene il tuo posto libero tutto d'ora in
poi amore per un'analisi ritmica cerca
garzanti la settima ma è ferita che non
si pu altro prossimo tatuaggio per
interview questa casa ha fatto dove
chiedere se tour parte raffaele così e
poi quelle unghie numeri nei pub bar da
donna di strada la tua amica quella
non siamo così il ragazzo con cui era
foto profilo presumo sia il suo
completino riconosco che una mamma io
vado telai di toni per la cabina
telefonica che mi chiamo maccarini che
arriva da giocare
messaggio col canale usato per carità si
sta ora faccio tutto io ti se metti più
quartieri ai cugini propria rete fermerà
mondiale ma ora vita mia sono scene
forti ideali e cellulare l'hai presa tu
mi raccomando scrivi tu che sei di
credito foulard che si fa freddo 24 nel
forno dove vai
esa negati che non mi vogliono però
tavolo genitori fratelli sorelle fedina
penale sporca
voglio una foto un ri concepiva di uno
di loro è anche la fotocopia della carta
d'identità sabbia è pronto o perche
cambiato canale 8 cucinando ma lo
sentono potente non ascolta qui è un
passo fondamentale nel segreto
mamma ho finito i soldi arrangiati da
che potresti farmi un caffè che ho fatto
due mani adesso ma mar domani una verità
devi solo da scusa per tempo le maglie
sono le nuove di settimane pendino degli
e cronache di per mito
io ho negato in quanto la base di una
nuova epoca nella casa quindi teniamoci
belotti è trattato signore non avevo
molto buono lui anche se piace
abbiamo gli stessi gusti come la fine
che citavo tipo della discoteca per un
cretino c'è mai fine
mai avvicinato più giro che il prossimo
0 qui verticali davvero dire qui mamma
ma cos'hai pronuncerà bolloré che si
deve partire anche la ragazza con cui
essi magari sono malata di vendere tutta
la città falsone
[Musica]